so in this module we're going to be
talking about the resolution which is an
inference rule so so far we've been
talking about propositional logic we've
been talking about syntax and semantics
of propositional logic and we discussed
one inference rule specifically modus
ponens and the idea of this of an
inference rule is can we do uh
manipulation of syntax in the syntactic
land over formulas in order to derive in
order to prove a new formula and the
idea is is that in france through under
that specific set of logic and logical
formulas is that sound and complete and
what we have seen is if i apply just
modus ponens on propositional logic i
get soundness but i don't get
completeness and then what that means is
if i have a bunch of formulas that are
entailed that are true i'm not going to
be able to get all of them if i apply
modus ponens on propositional logic so
we talked about two ways of solving that
and we discussed the first way the first
idea was instead of looking at all of
propositional logic let's look at a
subset of it and that subset is
propositional logic with only horn
classes so we defined foreign clauses
during the last module and we looked at
propositional logic with only horn
clauses and in that case if i apply
modus ponens then i get soundness and
completeness everything is great
the other option is what if i don't want
to limit my prepositional logic what if
i want to look at all of her positional
logic can i make my inference rule a
little bit fancier a little bit more
powerful
so in this module we are going to be
talking about a new type of inference
rule specifically called resolution as a
way of getting both soundness and
completeness
all right so
to start with i i want to just write out
a few things that that we're all aware
of but uh let's just get on the same
page on all of them so
um all right so
let me just write out a few things so so
if we have p twice q well what is that
equivalent to that is equivalence to
negation of p or q let's just write out
some of these equivalences here
if i get if i have negation of p
and if i have negation of p and q
what is that what is that equivalent to
well i can apply de morgan's law
and that gives me gets me negation of p
or negation of q and then if i have
negation of p
or q
what is that going to be that is going
to be equal to negation of p
and negation of q
remove these extra lines
all right so these are a few
equivalences that we all agree over this
is just how they are like
it's it's just like truth right so if
you look at the truth a truth table of
these you're gonna get you're going to
get these these equivalences and the
reason i'm defining these equivalences
is in general i would like to write
everything in the form of disjunctions
and conjunctions okay so let me define a
few other things here so so i'm going to
define
a literal
as a prepositional symbol p
or a negation of a proposed per
positional symbol negation of p okay so
a literal is just p or negation of p
where p is just a compositional symbol
okay
so then based on that one can define a
clause
to be a conjunction
sorry to be a disjunction of
prepositional symbols okay so we talked
about born clauses during the last
module but we never like defined what a
clause is so a clause is just an or of a
bunch of literals it's just a
disjunction of a bunch of literal so i
can have a clause that's like p1 or
negation of p2 maybe or p3 this is a
clause
because it's just an or of a bunch of
literals
so then the question is what is a
foreign clause so could we would you
find horn clauses last lecture but we
could think about horn clauses a little
bit differently here so a horn
clause it's basically a clause it's just
a disjunction of a bunch of literals
with at most one positive literal so i'm
going to refer to this guy as a positive
literal
and this guy as a negative literal
and a horned class basically says you
have at most one positive literal in in
your class for example this clause that
i've written here is not a horn clause
right because it has two positive
literals p1 and p3 but for example i can
have another horn clause that is p1 or
negation of p2
or
negation of p3
and then this is going to be um a horn
clause because it has at most one
positive literal that that is p1 okay so
this is just another way of looking at
horn clauses so going back here right so
we have a implies c how can we write it
we can write it as negation of a or c
we have a and b implying c right what is
that equal to it's negation of this
first part i can use the morgan's law
and that gives me negation of a or
negation of b or c remember like again
again this is this is a cause now and
it's a horn clause and and again like
defining what i've defined so far a
literal is going to be a prepositional
uh symbol either positive or negative
either p or negation of p a clause is
just a disjunction of these literals an
important clause is just a clause with
at most one positive literal okay
all right so now when i'm thinking about
modus ponens i can actually write it out
as as clauses right like remember i have
a and a implies c and that gets me c
that is what modus ponens tells me
instead of a implies c i can just write
it as a clause and i can write it as
negation of a or c okay
and kind of like intuitively like what
is really happening is you're cancelling
out a and negation of a that's why we
are getting c
okay
and the reason i'm defining modus ponens
like this i'm rewriting it is this kind
of helps us to think about this more
general resolution rule that i'll be
talking about in a few slides okay
so the idea of resolution is i don't
want to limit myself to specific types
of clauses i can talk about general
clauses and general clauses are what are
they there are disjunctions of of
positive or negative literals
and the idea of resolution is if you
have a bunch of clauses
you'll have a rule you'll have an
inference rule that cancels out your
positive and negative literals so here's
an example so if it is raining or
snowing that's part of your knowledge
base
and if it is not snowing or there is
traffic
one can infer that it is raining or
there is traffic
why let's think about like why can't we
why can't we infer this even intuitively
okay
so so if it is snowing right so so so if
it is snowing then there's got to be if
the snowing is true right there's got to
be traffic okay so that's how i get
traffic and if it is not snowing right
if it's not snowing then there's got to
be rain because it's either snowing or
or or raining so that's how i get rain
right so intuitively that is why you're
getting this rain or traffic and in some
sense you can think about snow and
negation of snow canceling each other
out because because either if it is
snowing or or or if it is not snowing
you are going to get traffic or rain out
of it
and then this is basically resolution
inference will apply to one example okay
one can think about this much more
generally and think about a clause f1 or
disjunctive through fn or p and then
another clause where you have negation
of p or g one through g m
and then the idea of an inference rule
is based on these two premises you can
conclude a new clause that cancels out p
and negation
so this is called resolution
all right
so is is resolution sound so that's a
very good question to ask in general we
want it to be sound because we want to
be able to derive things that are
actually true so is it like remember
this example is it true that i can
derive rain or traffic here okay so so
how do i check that well to check
soundness i need to actually get to the
models and meanings of each one of these
formulas and i need to check entailment
so let's check that on this example so
if i have rain or snow what is models of
rain or snow models of so so i have here
my my truth table is going to be a
little bit larger because i have both
snow rain and traffic so i need to look
at zero one values for all of them
so i have rain or snow rain or snow
correspond to these shaded areas so
that's models of rain or snow
and then i have models of
not snow or traffic that corresponds to
these shaded areas
and remember as i add more formulas to
my knowledge base i'm shrinking its
models right i'm adding more constraints
so i'm shrinking the models that is why
models of of these two formulas is going
to be the intersection of their models
so the intersection is going to be this
darker red area okay
so if i'm checking entailment if i'm
basically checking if resolution is
sound i should be checking entailment
and what that means is i should be
checking if the models of what is in my
knowledge base is going to be is is
going to be uh as a subset of models of
this new formula that i'm trying to
derive here so what's the new formula
i'm trying to derive here resolution
tells me you can derive rain or traffic
and if i look at rain or traffic and
models of rain or traffic i get this
green area so the question is is the
shade a dark dark red area uh a subset
of the green area and in this case it is
so so it turns out that the resolution
is actually sound so so in terms of
thinking about the models thinking about
the semantics here we are getting we are
getting soundness we are ensuring that
we are getting truth uh by applying
resolution okay so resolution is sound
so as you've kind of seen resolution
only works on clauses right like i've
been defining these clauses which are
disjunctions of literals and the
question is can i apply resolution to
all of propositional logic and the
answer is yes it actually turns out that
the fact because like if resolution only
works on clauses that is actually enough
and the reason that is actually enough
is you can think about any prepositional
formula and you can write any
prepositional formula as a conjunction
of a bunch of clauses and that's called
a conjunctive conjunctive normal form
okay so a conjunctive normal form a cnf
formula is a conjunction of clauses okay
so so an example of that is is it's you
have a clause a or b or negation of c
you have another clause negation of b or
d
and an end of these two clauses is is a
conjunct isn't a conjunctive normal form
okay so you can kind of like think of
this as the equivalent of having a
knowledge base where you have each
formula is a clause and then when you
have a bunch of formulas in your in your
knowledge base you're basically thinking
about end of those formulas right so so
a knowledge base basically is an end of
a bunch of a conjunction of a bunch of
formulas that could be written let's say
as clauses okay
all right so so then basically every
formula that that is written in
propositional logic can be converted
into a conjunctive normal form in a new
formula conjunctive normal form that's
that's exactly equal like the models of
the old formula is exactly equal to the
models of the new formula so how can we
do that um it's actually a
kind of um easy way of doing it it's
just there's just a recipe uh for for
trans for converting every formula to a
conjunctive normal form let's let's look
at an example so
let's say that you have a formula it
says summer implies no and the whole
thing implies bizarre okay
so um
here i don't have any ends or ors right
like i have this implication so i need
to get rid of that implication how can i
do that i can basically remove
implication and and write that write it
out in the form that i talked about
earlier which is negation of the first
term or the second term so this
implication i can write it as negation
of the first term this whole term or the
second term i can remove this
implication and write it in a similar
way i can write it as negation of summer
or snow okay so now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to push the negation inside
using the morgan's law so i'm going to
push a negation inside make this and
push negation inside i have a double
negation here i'm going to get rid of
that double negation and make this
positive
so now i have a bunch of literals
positive or negative and i only have
like ands and ors but this is actually
not in the conjunctive normal form right
because conjunctive normal form means
that and of a bunch of ores this is
actually the opposite right this is this
is or of a bunch of ants
but what you can you can you can
actually distribute this or over the end
and then you end up if you distribute
the or over the end you end up with
these two causes summer or bizarre and
another clause which is
negation of snow or bizarre
okay so so you end up in a cnf form any
formula you give me i can end up in a
cnn form so so the general recipe for it
is if you have if you have implications
or these bi-directional implications
replace them with ad and orders and
negations so that's the first thing you
want to do bi-directional implication
write it out as as
as implications and ants
if you see an implication write it out
as a form of negation and or
if you have any negations move them
inside using de morgan's law
if you have double negations remove the
double negations and then at the end
just distribute or over end if you have
if you have any anything of that form
and you'll end up in a conjunctive
normal form so that is kind of the
general recipe of converting any
propositional logic formula to a cnf
form okay
and then why are we writing this as a
cnf form because the resolution rule
works only on clauses which is it only
works on cnf form formulas
all right
so so what's the idea of resolution
algorithm well
why are we trying to run resolution the
reason is in general you might be asking
me if f is true or not right like we we
care about having that assistant that
they can ask from or we can tell it
things and and what does that do that
tries to basically check things like
entailment right so so if if the
knowledge base if you want to check if
the knowledge base is entailing a new
formula or not that's the same thing
right that's the same thing as checking
if negation of f if the knowledge base
contradicts negation of f or basically
checking if negation of f added to the
knowledge base is unsatisfiable or not
okay
so how do we run the resolution based
algorithm well what we do is if you ask
me if f is entailed or not i'll add
negation of f to my knowledge base and
then i convert all my formulas to cnf
form we can do that and once i have
everything to cn in a cnf form i can
apply resolution i can keep repeatedly
applying resolution until until
everything is converged and then i can
return entailment even only if i'm
deriving false okay
so that is how we run resolution if if
we want to answer a question about
entailment
let's look at an example here so let's
say i have a knowledge base this is my
knowledge base it has a bunch of things
in it they're not in a cnn form they're
not in a class form or anything but but
i have a bunch of formulas and and
you're asking me if if this knowledge
base entails a new formula and that new
formula is c so how do i check that
using resolution what i'm going to do is
i'm going to add a negation of c to my
knowledge base i'm going to make
everything to the to a cnf form so using
that recipe that i talked about removing
implications and pushing pushing
negations in and distributing wars over
things right once i do that everything
is in a class form i have a clause and i
have literals okay so so this is my this
is my uh knowledge base everything is in
the class form in a cnf form
and then i'm going to repeatedly apply a
resolution so how do i apply resolution
let's start from from these two so i
have a and i have negation of a or b or
c in some sense a and negation of a gets
cancelled out so i can add b or c to my
to my knowledge base using resolution
okay i have negation of b in my in my
knowledge base so so negation of b and b
get cancelled out and i can add c to my
knowledge base and i've added negation
of c to my knowledge base of negation of
c and
and c get cancelled out and i'll get
false okay so after repeatedly applying
resolution here i'm getting false
meaning that when i add negation of the
formula i i was able to get this
contradiction i was able to get false
and what that means is that knowledge
base actually entails the formula the
formula being c in this case okay so
knowledge base in klc yeah i can derive
c okay
all right so
a good question to ask is what is the
time complexity of these and these
algorithms so so if you remember modus
ponens right like the idea of modus
ponens this was a more general form of
it was that at every step right like we
would at most uh kind of like add one
prepositional symbol uh to to our to our
knowledge base and if you're adding one
prepositional symbol like if you have
like n of them you have at most like n
things to go over so so this would be a
linear time algorithm like when you're
running modus ponens it's pretty simple
it's it's it's also converges fairly
quickly because our end things that we
need to go over
but when we think about uh
this this inference rule resolution but
when we were thinking about resolution
we are adding many prepositional symbols
back to our back to our um knowledge
base and then kind of like worst case
you're adding all the subsets of
of the disjunctions of these these
symbols into our to our uh knowledge
base at the end too so what that means
is you have to go over all of them and
then that takes exponential time right
so so running resolution is in terms of
time complexity it takes exponential
time
and it's actually not surprising that it
takes exponential time if you think
about what resolution is doing is it's
actually trying to solve a
satisfiability problem right like you
have pauses and and and these clauses
and you want to find you we want to
check satisfiability here you're doing
model shaking and that satisfiability is
known to be mp complete so it's not
surprising that that running resolution
until convergence actually takes
exponential time
so there are really some trade-offs here
like if you think about using horn
clauses uh you could you could use modus
ponens the nice thing about it is that
it's going to be linear time but it is
less expressive you're not able to
represent everything in propositional
logic you're only limited to foreign
clauses but one classes turn that turn
out to be kind of useful for for many
applications especially some
applications in programming languages so
so in those applications it does make
sense to use modus ponens because it
it's faster it takes linear time on the
other hand if you really care about all
of your positional logic then you really
care about dealing with any type of
causes and there you have to use
resolution but the problem with
resolution is it's trying to solve an
np-complete problem it takes exponential